der schweiß leute ich bin gerade hinter
rooney ich habe mich raus geschlichen
irgendein daumen nebenan nimmt egal für
euch auf weil ich erstmal bescheid geben
möchte was gerade bei mir so abläuft und
zwar schreibt ich gerade klos und ich
studiere ja viele von euch wissen und
momentan ist gerade die phase im studium
am ende jedes messers wo man in jedem
fach mit klausur schreibt bleibt auch so
einen lärm muss und kein leben hat und
die sache ist dass in diesem semester so
viel lernen muss mehr als jedem semester
vor ungefähr 1500 2000 folien insgesamt
nicht für die fächer lernen also ultras
viel dafür teppich und es ist momentan
einfach so dass ich gerade überhaupt
keinen zettel gar nichts habe ich komme
nicht zum sport ich komme nicht zum
leben ich konnte eigentlich zum videos
machen deswegen wollte ich mit dem video
anfang bescheid geben was gerade bei mir
so abgeht ich habe null zeit ich muss
den ganztag dann lernte ich die morgens
in die uni und um mitternacht oder
später wieder nach hause und ich krieg
hat momentan gar nichts gebacken so
außer lernen deswegen kam letztlich zu
wenig videos und horia bescheid geben
die klausuren phase geht bei mir noch
bis zum 31
ab dem 1 es ist mein kann wieder normal
videos für euch machen würde ich einfach
mal informieren was carla bei mir
passiert also ich bin nicht gestorben
ich bin nicht entführt worden weil dort
vielleicht wohin führt vielleicht wird
in diesem raum purer festgehalten ich
finde wir sollten einfach wissen was
kampagne abgeben was der grund dafür ist
momentan keine videos kommen und vor
allem wann es wieder richtige wie es
gibt also spätestens am 31
am ersten juni wieder richtig und
regelmäßig videos um ich mir ja darauf
mit fehlt des videos machen ehrlich
gesagt schon das zum 31 mai muss ich
schauen wie ich die videos bekommen
natürlich leute verhalten sich das
gefragt haben ich kann mich auch weiter
noch jeden tag mit rauchen dass diese
verständlicher videos machen deshalb
momentan
schwierig aber ich habe eine gute video
idee hier auf jeden fall noch vom 31
kommt eine kleinigkeit zugelegt wir
sehen ja das war's so weit von diesem
lebenszeichen von mir als natürlich ab
dem ersten juni geht wieder und habe
meine kommentare ob er so was richtig
findet dass youtube mehr was dann
passierte baums keine wie es gibt für
mich interessieren auf jeden fall bis
zum nächsten video haut rein machten